the gap between using a Japanese toilet
and using a conventional toilet is
roughly equivalent to the gap between
using a conventional toilet and shooting
in a bucket in prison okay right okay
that's roughly speaking with you know
the uh the yawning sense of kind of
reversion you feel when you go from
using a Japanese toilet to a
conventional one it's barbaric it's
ridiculous nearly just stop
I'm drinking liquid death are you
familiar with this the can yes water
brand tasty water is it sparkling water
off or still I've never had it this is
sparkling so the black can sparkling and
the white can is still ah I watched a
very interesting advertisement uh come
analysis uh that the founder put across
where he explained The Branding strategy
behind liquid death calling something
literally the opposite of what it is
having a very sort of unique brand
position it's got this skull on it there
yes
um what's your thoughts on liquid death
uh what's interesting about it is that
um uh funnel enough a uh something
rather weird as I pretty much dislike
drinking water
um from a tap or any other shape or form
weirdly I quite like drinking water from
a can and I have no idea why that is so
I've started buying drinking far more
water than I did before now you can get
it in canned form rather than bottle
form actually it's not quite true I'm
pretty happy drinking it from glass but
I don't like drinking water from plastic
bottles do you know what my favorite
brand of sparkling water is if you had
Topo Chico before
no you'll have to okay you'll have to
enlighten me on that so it's Mexican
sparkling water and there is a uh
carbonation grade and I think uh a San
pellegrinos maybe at a 90 ish on this
particular spectrum and Topo Chico's
140. so this thing just feel it's like a
fizzy battery it just takes a face it's
the same new carbonated yeah something
enough the Germans have various sort of
often fairly cheaps brutal glasses which
are again insanely carbonated which I've
always really liked
um and um
uh it's uh it's generally quite
interesting there's a very good water
with strong enough uh you only seem to
get now at um Crown Plaza Hotels which
is a Welsh water uh which I like very
much as well which I think is called
it's called something like Cambrian but
it isn't called that
um but I think the idea I mean
effectively uh The Branding will have
totally affect the experience because
um uh you know packaging affects taste
is it true it's a conspicuous
consumption do you think for a for an
age where alcohol is less cool than it
might be it might have used to be
yeah I mean I I like the sheer
perversity of saying call something the
opposite of of what it really is
um there was obviously a brand called
Death cigarettes back in the day in the
early 90s which was from the ethical
tobacco company and they said we're
going to sell cigarettes we're just not
going to lie about them
and that was similar uh that that had a
kind of black packaging and a skull on
it
um
and um uh no I mean what what is
undoubtedly true is you can um I mean
you know I mean all alcoholic drinks
Brands know this you know that you're
drinking imagery as much as you're
drinking a drink
and um uh you know the associations are
as powerful as the reality essentially
and I hadn't tried liquid death I'll be
intrigued to know what what effect it
has on me good quality what's this this
is a 500 mil as well which is a nice
sized can I'll tell you what else I've
been obsessed with recently have you
watched first class airplane cabin
reviews on YouTube yeah I've watched
quite a few of those why are they so
compelling what is it about them
I don't know
um it's um uh it's kind of interesting
because
in a way when you think about it an
experience in an airline's first class
is other than the food it's not all that
fantastic is it because you're still
confined to a very small space you have
to share a toilet okay you know uh
you've got one seat to sit in you can't
actually you know I mean some of the
more elaborate cabins now you have your
own desk in a swivel chair and you just
knows what else admittedly
um
but it is surprisingly and weirdly
interesting I quite like the idea they
have an Emirates which is if you have a
cabin in the middle you have these
windows which appear to be the windows
of a plane but are in fact a video
reproduction of what you would see if
you're looking out of a window no way I
haven't done that yet that is
interesting implications for
um uh you know Airline design ultimately
it's an interesting question you know it
must be presumably cheaper and safer to
build aircraft without windows but you
have to have Windows to stop passengers
going nuts I did see once the most
extraordinary thing which was a it was
obviously a design project rather than a
serious proposal but it was effectively
an airliner where uh you know more or
less half the inside of the fuselage was
video screens uh with a you know
effectively showing a picture of the
exterior so you almost felt you were
traveling in a transparent plane wow
which would almost magically weird I
suspect that's cool that would make for
so I I mean it does it does one of the
interesting things actually is that 4K
for quite a lot of quite a lot of
functions 4K TV isn't that much better
than HD
um HD I think most people can tell the
difference between HD and standard
definition certainly if you're in the
United States where the standard
definition picture which had fewer lines
than the European picture was
particularly crap actually I mean
American standard definition television
um was rubbish even compared to European
Standard definition TV and HD is you
know markedly better and clearer
particularly when he was playing
something like text or detail and that
kind and 4K is quite interesting because
it doesn't really make much difference
if you're watching let's say soccer or
football
because when you've got a lot of
movement going on a I think there's a
lot of blurring anyway but actually your
brain's doing most of the work
your brain's effectively assembling the
um the image from what information it
has when things are moving very fast so
if you notice whenever you go into a TV
store and they have 4K or in extreme
cases 8K screens on display it'll always
show like a static close-up picture of
an ant next to a blob of water or a
flower it's a jellyfish slowly moving in
slow very very slowly moving or a night
sky over um you know imaginary remember
do you remember when Joe Rogan first
moved to Austin and he went into a
studio that was this big red thing it
kind of looked like the inside of a
flashlight and the first few episodes
that he released in this new studio
everybody was unhappy about it they
couldn't tell what was wrong but they
said this is awful it looks terrible and
I can't work out why it's because he was
filming it in 60 frames per second
they'd moved there and they'd put it in
60 FPS instead of I think 25 and this I
learned this because this um YouTube
channel did a great breakdown of what
was wrong with it and then they fixed it
and switched it back to 25 or 30 perhaps
and the issue is that your eyes
naturally see blur so if you hold your
hand up in front of your face and you
wiggle it left and right you actually do
see this blur you don't see every single
frame of where your hand is no and what
that means is that 60 FPS is displaying
a type of video that your eyes are not
used to seeing in the real world which
is what makes it feel so artificial
are interesting interesting so
um I wonder why I said nearly all TV has
broadcasted 25 is it 25 yeah 24. ah
interesting yeah that that's that's
fascinating obviously you have you know
things like the the mag uh the Apple
Retina screen where there's no point in
making a screen that's uh any finer
since we wouldn't be able to tell the
difference
um what is interesting about 4K is that
it does get close enough if you if
you've got a reasonably slow moving
image and there is that interesting you
know hypothetical debate
um uh which is you know
ultimately either through virtual
reality or just through really good
streams is there a perfectly acceptable
form of virtual tourism now I must admit
I'm glad you're a YouTube fanatic the
thing I always recommend people do is
subscribe to YouTube premium oh Rory
yeah you are among friends here I'm also
we must be on a tiny matter of few
people because I've got a friend at
YouTube and I keep asking how many
people actually subscribe to premium and
it's a pretty vanishingly small number I
did it I think more or less by accident
and it was practically the best thing
that ever happened to me in life and
we're reaching a point I think
where the volume of content on YouTube
has become so vast that
it's only well maybe maybe it's already
happened but it's only a smidgen away
from becoming effectively Wikipedia with
video in other words it becomes so
comprehensive
uh this extraordinary kind of
um assemblage of virtually every
conceivable
um you know uh subject treated to on
video that you'll reach a point where
effectively there'll be a film on
everything yep
um and and the two things I really
recommend with YouTube is I said first
of all
um watch it on your Telly you know
because you know we all have this very
early memory of YouTube where it was all
you know handheld slightly pixelated all
a bit crap and you there was no party
watching it on TV because it would have
you know effectively pixelated and
actually you know the vast majority of
the content actually is uh if not
professionally produced it's you know
sort of broadcast quality and I do spend
occasionally one of the things I really
love is really really slow TV so you get
these 4K walking tours of Cebu in the
Philippines for example you know that
was one of them and it's just someone
with a 4k camera wandering around Cebu
for an hour and a half and it's
surprisingly worthwhile in fact
um you know that obviously um
uh that's one of one of my favorite ones
is virtual rail fan which is basically
an American YouTube channel often live
webcams for train spotters and when I'm
working at home I leave this on in the
background and effectively you just get
a tiny amount of battery if it's in a
station yeah you'll get a tiny amount of
background noise or cars driving past
and then you get on with your work and
then about every half hour a train goes
past and you kind of take a break to to
stare at it for the seven minutes it
takes to pass the screen there's a
there's a guy that does City tours
walking at night and uh the the a lot of
the time in rain and there's something
about that which is oddly very very
therapeutic I saw an article that I
wanted to bring up actually
um 50 of Americans watch content with
subtitles most of the time 55 say it is
harder to hear dialogue in shows and
movies than it used to be nearly three
and four respondents claimed muddled
audio from their content and 61 use them
when accents are difficult to understand
29 prefer to watch their content at home
quietly leaving subtitles on so as not
to disturb their roommates or family and
27 of Americans rely on subtitles to
keep them focused on what they are
watching while juggling the distractions
of multiple screens children pets work
the news and more
so interestingly if you go back to the
1970s
um uh not that they broadcast many of
them but Americans would impose
subtitles on Australian content in
particular
which seems you know I think it's if
I've got this right prisoners prisoner
cell blockage was the first Australian
sort of soap if you can call it that uh
to be broadcast in the US without
subtitles
well there's a you'll always see this
even in the UK especially for us because
we have such a panoply of different
accents that you could get stuck into
what I always find hilarious is when
they hard code Subs onto certain people
perhaps in a documentary or whatever the
policeman there's no subtitles but the
criminal with a very strong scouse
accent he's he's been forced to have
this because they've just made a
decision like look no one is going to be
able the cohort of people that can
understand this man is like five so
we're just going to put them on the
screen for everybody so funny enough
it's another of my friends who also has
YouTube premium who is one of the first
to point out that actually subtitles
um have uh uh are generally preferable
in all kinds of ways and is it and of
course Brits got used to it probably
with scandi drama unless you're into
French Art House or something it was
probably scandi drama that really got
Brits into subtitle watching it's it
does force you to pay attention it stops
you dozing off
because you have to look at the screen
to know what's going on
um I find the diction and enunciation of
a lot of modern actors pretty poor you
know I mean you one thing you say with
your life about Kerry Grant but he
didn't exactly Mumble you know what I
mean I mean you know it was okay it was
a bizarre hybrid of a bristolian English
and American accent you know we can
probably all accept that by the way one
thing that Brits are very talented at is
linguists and it's through necessity is
being able to understand English spoken
in a very wide range of accidents so
we're always said to be very bad at
languages well yes and no I mean one
thing we're pretty good at is being
being able to understand more or less
anybody speaking English and it's partly
our own Regional actions give us
practice the one you'll love if you're
from the Northeast
is that the Elder Stevenson inventor of
the steam locomotive had such a strong
Geordie accent that when he presented
the locomotive in London he was
accompanied by an interpreter
no no
um
there was James and there was the Elder
one the father I mean I think I think
the father said you know the son to a
lot of fancy schools was presumably he'd
made enough money by then but the Elder
Stevenson would apparently go to London
for demonstrated to go right yeah I
agree but you know the bastard
what Mr Stevens wants to say is that the
addition of a boiler to the locomotive
will facilitate that right
it's just absolutely fantastic wow very
interesting actually when you think
about it that most I was making a joke
suggestion for the electric car the
other day which is to say that the
actual actually the internal combustion
engine is unnatural and evil because
it's the only form of Motive Power not
invented in the UK uh uh yes so the
diesel and the petrol engine are
basically Continental inventions pretty
much everything else electric motor
probably Faraday Sterling engine steam
engine watt Etc and what's quite
interesting is actually that um and so
many of these things were kind of
invented I mean what being one obvious
case Faraday himself to a degree
although he was he became an assistant
to Andrew David but they're actually
uneducated people which is kind of
interesting
um you know they were tinkerers and
Fiddlers in you know and they had access
to the right tinkering equipment have
you read Winston Churchill's Ministry of
ungentlemanly warfare
I've heard of it but tell me more this
is if I could give you a single book
that I think is the most Rory book that
I've read over the last 12 months this
would be it so um in the build up to the
beginning of World War II a bunch of
bigwigs in the UK government realized
that war seems to be afoot and they
realize that we are woefully
unprepared to be able to fight a war
with this level of brutality and the
reason that he calls it ungentlemanly
Warfare is that there was a point where
uh guerrilla warfare uh sabotage of key
Bridges and and stuff was seen as being
such an uncouth military strategy that a
British military General was actually
quoted as saying if this is what it
takes to win the war I'm prepared to
lose he basically saw that he had this
sort of stiff upper lip type of
discipline with regards to the way it's
absolutely okay to fight combatants but
to crap people's General quality or it
rather sort of crop burning and all that
would be too much so what they did the
reason that the tinkerer thing got me
onto this was that he they try and
create this web of miscreants basically
so this um garage inventor who'd created
a three stories high Caravan that was
only able to go across certain roads
because of the bridge clearance he
needed he made the world's first Limpet
mine so the Limpet mine that was
deposited into a sea and would then
attach with a magnet and would then blow
up a U-boat and stuff and the way that
they did it was so cottage industry this
is why you love it so for instance they
needed to find a primer that would
dissolve at the exact right rate and the
solution that they came up to having
gone through everything was aniseed seed
balls so the aniseed sweets that you
would have and the reason they needed
that they needed something to separate
out the two electrical contacts so it
wouldn't fire too quickly it wouldn't
fire too slowly and they tried
everything they also tried the reality
ball was perfect was it because in salt
water it would be what sort of a number
of minutes yep 30 30 minutes exactly
let's say for this particular type so
and then they wrapped it they wrapped
the entire thing to make sure that this
aniseed ball didn't start to dissolve
too quickly in condoms and I can't
remember where it was that they were
doing this it was maybe in let's say it
was in like Sussex or something like
that uh some little village in Sussex
and the guy that wrote the book says
it's unclear whether or not there was an
increase in the number of children born
nine months later after this the town of
Sussex noticed that every single
because they were trying to do it
subversively they needed to go into
Little Village stores and buy but yeah
that's that's fantastic and the the
tinkering thing makes a lot of sense as
well but legitimate wolf setting is
interesting because uh one of my sort of
favorite characters I think I'm fairly
sure it was Admiral Coburn uh who almost
started the war of 1812 in the United
States and uh he was uh part of the
group which um along with us you know a
bunch of Canadians as well who burned
the White House Down which is why it's
the White House to cover the smoke
damage and so on oh it wasn't the white
house before
I I I've got a very good idea that was
painted white thereafter
um because of smoke damage but I have to
double check on this but he was
certainly the guy who burnt the Senate
how the Senate and the capital down
um in in this war of 1812 and um he was
a kind of
libertarian military man who was
absolutely an assistant that you could
you could damage National Property
because it was uh you know the property
of the seditious Yankee state but you
must not damage private property and he
only made one exception there was a
newspaper that was very rude about him
and I think he just broke into the
newspaper and destroyed all their letter
K's so they couldn't write about him
but his troops were under strict
instructions you know Town Halls that's
fine you can burn those down but if it's
private property you don't touch it
which is kind of quite interesting why
do you think um you mentioned earlier on
about VR why do you think that vr's not
necessarily taken off mainstream
adoption the way that some people might
have predicted well there's also a
strange one which is why we have why we
don't use computers wearing goggles as
well I mean just regardless of any
3dness even in 2D you could presumably
have a fantastic and enormous screen as
an interface you know an interface which
possibly had you know but I mean okay we
need to see the keyboard I guess would
touch typists be better off but but it
always strikes me a strange that just
watching a film with using goggles which
of course you can do on Oculus device or
meta devices now
um uh isn't more popular because it's a
very cheap way of getting a huge screen
in a way
um
and okay some of it seems to be sort of
slight feelings of vertigo or sickness
and I'm not sure they've actually
cracked that
there are certainly a large number of
cases where I wouldn't use it so I'd
probably feel pretty comfortable using
VR goggles on a plane but not on a train
it was on a train I'd be convinced that
either someone was going to Nick my
briefcase or that I might be stabbed
from the high you know that you'd
actually just you know if you think if
you think about it I mean the whole
thing is very interesting on the
headphones question
because
um I bought before Christmas as a pure
experiment these bone conducting
headphones
uh which you don't wear over your area I
I can't wear in-ear headphones I I
genuinely whether it's the shape of my
ears just age habits it just straight to
me is completely bizarre you know uh and
I've I've struggled with in-ear
headphones and I've bought them and I've
tried different sizes of
the sort of Dutch plug device and so on
I you know but I can't make them work
and also I'm a plane for example I'm
terrified they'll just fall out get
trapped in the seat mechanism and you
know the whole thing will be a disaster
and so I'm always a big fan of
over-the-air headphones and noise
canceling headphones
um which worked for me very well as you
can see
um but these bone conducting things are
interesting because they don't actually
cover your ears at all and so your
ability to hear things in the outer
world is well it's not completely
unimpeded because obviously you have a
lot of noise coming from something else
but they were they're intended for
joggers but actually they're also
brilliant for old people with hearing
loss because the sound goes straight to
your effectively straight into your
cheekbones and so if your ears have
become generally damaged through gen you
know what you might call the subtle I
was at the Anvil and the Stirrup and so
forth if they've become a bit clogged up
and less flexible it bypasses that part
of your ear which has been damaged and
kind of goes straight into sensation now
my experience with burnt conducting
headphones
um and I think which magazines review
kind of bears this out is that for music
it's a bit [__] still I mean I have to
say it's not brilliant Fidelity is just
not there
it's missing something I mean you can
hear it hear all the lyrics you can
enjoy it to an extent but it it doesn't
really do it but for spoken content
particularly podcasts I'd say it's
absolutely brilliant you know I find it
um because one of the things is a you
can walk around wearing these things for
ages because they just hook over your
ears okay and then there's a little
thing which makes very mild pressure
against your cheek so
um and for answering phone calls having
a phone call you can forget you're
wearing these things now that's not true
of over-the-ear headphones where your
ears will overheat and you also have
that mild sense of disorientation yeah
I'm I'm I do see young people walking
around with
um noise canceling headphones or as I
call them to the fury my wife canceling
headphones
um
but but I you know I see people walking
around I couldn't do it myself I think
because I'd feel some sort of loss of
almost a lot of balance in other words
they're too immersive in that sense so
these bone conducting things are
definitely part of the solution you know
if you wanted to just wander around
London listening to a podcast without
getting hit by a van
um I have to say that pretty good idea
and actually what's a bit tragic is of
course because because of that whole
thing of traffic and awareness they're
being marketed to Young joggers when I
would say that 50 of the market is
actually people over 50. yeah yeah you
know whose hearing just isn't quite so
good am I making this up or about 20
years ago was there a brand of Lollipop
that was released for kids that came
attached to something that looked a lot
like the base of a electric toothbrush
and it would play a song while you
sucked on the Lollipop by going through
the lollipop in terms of vibration I
swear that I'm not making this up in my
mind if it's not the case though imagine
this let's say that you need to get kids
to brush their teeth and they need to
use an electric toothbrush there must be
a way that you could induct a song as
opposed to just the vibrations of the
actual toothbrush through the mouth of
the child so that they would actually
enjoy the one minute and 20 seconds or
however long a infant needs to brush it
I think in two two minutes I think might
be the optimal time for an electric
toothbrush yes
maybe they could you know dance around
while they're listening to it I don't
know that seems like a potentially cool
solution if you could somehow blend both
of these Technologies together because
then they must be very closely linked
because when you think about it when you
are cleaning your teeth particularly
with an electric toothbrush it is
impossible to hear anything on the radio
anything that's being said to you yeah
so in other words you know the vibration
must be effectively drowning out all use
of your ears yes I mean I I love I love
the Japanese Road organ which you
probably know of which is a series of
kind of um
corrugated strips on the road
oh and the idea is
exactly if you drive at the legal speed
it plays a nice tune
and if you drive too quickly presumably
it's absolutely awful so if you imagine
lots of uh those of you who know the
southwestern quadrant of the M23 M25
which is this most appalling stretch of
ribbed concrete still which which was
never tar backed and where you have to
drive along suddenly enough that
actually has a rather negative rather
negative effect because the vibration is
less unpleasant the faster you go
really Welly it's just to make that just
to make that stretch of the M25
tolerable it's a bit around Cobham yeah
but the Japanese one is quite sensible
because it's it's various little
different vibrations which plays a cutie
Little tune in terms of your tire knives
it provide at the tune only sounds only
good if you're traveling at the legal
speed have you heard about this new jet
that's going to come and basically
replace what Concord would have been so
a transatlantic
supersonic jet that's going to get
people across from New York to London in
no time at all
it's an interesting one isn't it I mean
it's still by the way there are still
weird problems they're always struck me
with supersonic travel
um
one of which is that unless you can
actually make it work across land and on
a wide variety of routes
um it isn't that big a time saving to
any one given individual you know unless
you you know unless you cross the
Atlantic you know practically weekly
um so unless you can actually create a
network of SuperSonic Jets rather than
just one route but the other thing that
always strikes me is fundamentally
flawed with the idea is the eastbound
leg
because everybody goes Concord
absolutely marvelous used to wake up in
New York before you taken off in London
which was true you could leave London in
at 10 o'clock and you'd basically arrive
in New York at something like 8 45 in
time for breakfast yeah Phil Collins has
once played Live Aid in the UK and then
flew to the US and played the same time
slot I think
you're right I think I think that's
right yeah that would have been yeah
and the interesting thing there though
is that eastbound it really doesn't work
because the best way to there are only I
think there are only about three or four
day flights between New York and London
the airlines don't like them because you
have a plane sitting on the tarmac
overnight not making any money
okay so the airlines really don't like
day flights I think they just do it out
of necessity with what you might call
the last flight of the day to land
um and um the interesting problem is
that if you think about it I think
concord's return flights let me hear
this ride I got a vague idea there was
one which where you left at about nine
in the morning and and it landed at
about five and I might have the idea
there was another that landed that went
at 11 in the morning with the one that
went at seven in the morning there were
two flights that used to come in I
always remember there was one around
about sort of five five o'clock five
thirty six it would land in Heathrow and
you'd hear it coming over London
but that's a singularly useless return
Journey because hey you've got to have a
totally pointless night in the hotel
where you get up really early and have
to get to JFK by I don't have seven
something or other right
um and um
and then then effectively you you lose a
complete day while you're awake flying
back
and uh most people I would have thought
for the return leg would have preferred
to have left the evening before on a 10
o'clock flight and woken up the
following morning in London yeah
especially if you're not staying in
London once you arrive there if you're
going on somewhere from London you're
going to have to probably get it exactly
yeah yeah so so the the your absolutely
right so the um uh the uh the um what
were you saying the onward flight okay
you know you might have missed the last
flight to Milan or whatever it might
have been but into that so there are
some it always strikes me that everybody
always bigged up the glories of Concord
going east to west which seemed to me
fairly I agree is there's something
rather wonderful about leaving London in
the morning and having a full day in New
York
um
uh but at the same time I suppose you
can still do
I suppose you can still you can still
kind of leave London fairly early and
get into New York at what would it be
noon didn't they need to uh
reinforce runways wasn't there an issue
with runways that the tires were sinking
into them because of the pace that or
the the weight perhaps it was a it was a
very high landing speed if I'm right
I'm fairly sure that it landed at a much
faster speed than most other planes did
yeah I was talking to a friend who was a
uh he was doing civil engineering at Uni
and he was telling me about uh the
project was remapping newcastle's
International Airport and one of the
things that they needed to do is you
need to your your
um planes that are allowed to land are
limited by width length uh density of
the tarmac and concrete underneath
there's a whole bunch of things that
actually restrict the type of planes
that are able to land so I imagine that
somewhere at Heathrow there must still
be a
Concord compatible but slightly aged
Runway perhaps I think I think the main
Runway at Heathrow would probably be
reinforced to that level given the
volume of traffic it takes yes
um
I know that the the space shuttle had um
obviously a number of emergency runways
around the world uh where it could land
and you also get this slightly weird
thing where you get freakishly long
runways where you don't expect them in
places like I think Morgan which is new
key airport has an incredibly long
Runway because it was originally a
military aircraft airport
the runways
so the rumble is incredibly long
and so I know the space shuttle had to
have this various kind of there was this
worldwide network of places it could
land in an emergency it never actually I
don't think it ever took advantage of
any of them
um because with the space shuttle when
things went wrong they went really wrong
yes the emergency landing is not the
biggest yeah this was never never an
issue yes um but no I mean I mean the
other thing the other thing in a sense
is that
um the time saving is not quite as
pronounced with um supersonic flight as
you might hope and it doesn't work
either if there's no reliable way of
getting to the airport on time and if if
JFK doesn't build a train to the airport
you basically have to leave to you know
two and a half hours before your flight
to be confident of getting there okay
that's one problem and then the amount
of time now obviously with the Concord
they reduce the amount of time you had
to spend [__] around at the airport
to some degree and the amount of time
you had to spend [__] around at
arrivals I know I don't think you went
through the standard U.S immigration
procedure because imagine how maddening
that would be to go on the Concorde for
you know and pay a fortune to go and
then three detained in an immigration
queue for two hours so they did these
cut down other parts of the journey as
well as the parts in flight
um but I mean you know that the the pain
of getting to an airport really adds
three hours to the beginning of any
long-haul flight unless you live
spectacularly close to Heathrow and
you're happy really dosing it tell you
what um have you ever done the journey
to America through Dublin where you
immigrate into America in Ireland well
I've done I've done the equivalent which
was the which still is actually the
British Airways right from London City
where you land in Shannon to refuel you
clear immigration in Shannon and then
you do an unborn slide
uh it's west coast of Ireland it's
actually very beautiful I mean it's
unbelievably and it's you you come in
right next to the River Shannon and it's
unbelievably green and lovely the reason
is that the 757 couldn't take off from
London city with a completely full fuel
load
and so what they did is they combined if
if you like they made a virtue out of
necessity which is they said okay well
take off with a partial fuel load it was
business class only seating
um
um uh there's one slide today I think
well they may have killed it under covid
London city and then you you landed in
Shannon while they're refueling the
plane or rather topping the the plane up
with fuel to the full load in Shannon
you then clear U.S immigration which you
can do in Dublin Shannon and knock and
if you know where else and then then
when when you arrive in New York you
basically walk straight out it's an
internal flight yeah yeah um what do you
think about chat GPT and how it's going
to impact advertising and the Behavioral
Science World
foreign
at some level it's it is unbelievably
impressive okay
in that it kind of passes a sort of
Turing test doesn't it
in that you wouldn't know it wasn't
written by a human and you know in some
of its things like you know mimicking
other writers and so on it you know it's
not fabulous but it doesn't do an
atrocious job by any means you know Bob
Dylan song lyrics or PG Woodhouse or
whatever else you try and get it to um
emulate but um
uh no how would I describe it I
one alarming facet it had which is that
um a colleague of mine in New York
called Chris Graves and he's made a big
scene about this and Linkedin he asked
it to explain a couple of cognitive
biases in the social science literature
uh around human behavior
and chat GPT came up with an extremely
good and intelligent description of what
these biases are and he said well that's
handy you seem to know a lot about this
please can you cite academic sources
this has really got really weird
it made up academic papers that don't
exist
it just took a few academics to some of
whom had published in the field and some
of whom hadn't
and it's somehow instead of saying okay
here are the reliable sources from which
I derived my knowledge of uh you know
human psychological biases it just said
okay what what do citations look like
what what do um
academic references look like
um I will create a plausible version of
these and in the process it effectively
invented completely non-existent
academic papers
which which is when you think about it
is really weird
what do you think it's doing so
but cheating I think I think it's you
know it's essentially suggests that it
doesn't know what the truth is
uh in a funny kind of way and it merely
goes how can I say this in a way that
looks plausible I mean that I mean
because
I mean you know two or three of the
academic excited in these papers which
they'd never written
um were actually social science
academics in one case it was a bit weird
because the person seemed to be an
expert on magnetic resonance nothing to
do with social science at all but it's
not safe it's interesting
and to use it as a curiosity it seems
absolutely fair but equally it's not
totally safe I read an article that was
very interesting and said that the
prediction this particular author's
prediction was that chat GPT will become
the biggest search engine in the world
because what you're doing when you go to
Google is you're looking for an existing
article to be discovered by Google that
will give you an answer to the question
that you're posing whereas what you do
when you go to chat GPT is to just get
the answer directly so you say I want to
make a Manhattan cocktail and Google
would bring you up
400 million different results from blog
blogs explaining what a Manhattan
cocktail is whereas you type in the
actual query to chat GPT now one of the
problems here is that if there are
biases
if there are some sort of predisposition
if it's been trained on a particular
type of language
you're going to potentially impact
because there's no crowdsourcing right
it just gives you a single answer uh so
yeah that's a concern as well
yeah I mean that you know well you know
it's very heavily reliant on Wikipedia
and I personally found Wikipedia pretty
okay but a lot of people accused of
political bias
um
I mean it was interesting in a sense in
that
um I didn't write my own Wikipedia page
someone else did
um but uh for various reasons I mean uh
it was very very difficult getting a
Wikipedia page because once you work in
advertising there are a load of people
who basically assume that anybody
working in advertising is doing this for
reasons of self-publicity and so people
who have no idea who I was they were I
think Chinese or Japanese uh or
something of that kind well you know
somebody wrote a page for me and then it
kept getting deleted
and the person will go this just looks
like advertising to me well and that was
partly because I work in advertising so
very obviously
um and
it um it and you know you can argue that
we you know I don't know how impartial
Wikipedia is politically it doesn't seem
atrocious to me I mean it doesn't seem
nakedly biased but it would surprise me
equally if the people who are the most
active Wikipedia contributors or editors
are a realistic cross-sectional Society
right because it takes a pretty damn
weird it takes a pretty damn weird
person to want to do that to be
absolutely honest okay very correct I
saw a
visualization of the difference between
gpt3 and gpt4 and the answer before is
the one that's not yet released correct
yeah yeah it's not it's not out yet um
however apparently gpt4 is going to be
able to write a 60 000 word book from a
single prompt in less than a minute
because of the amount of data that it's
been trained on it's some obscene amount
of data
and they're too frightened to release it
is that right not ready yet not ready I
think it'll still be being trained
um I've had a contrarian view which it
isn't actually uh set to replace the
search engine the proper place where
this belongs is kind of inside Microsoft
Office
how so where you have people who I
suppose the idea is you have people who
have work to do and you could say Okay
um if you could actually talk to because
what has to say actually for all its
faults it's comprehension is very good
isn't it
its level of comprehension of a question
or of a request is you know remarkably
good compared to Alexa for example
um I haven't yet tried it on banal
things like train times which always
strikes me as one of the weirdest Alexa
failings that you can't say can you tell
me the the times of the next trains from
this station to somewhere else oh that's
it or how long is it going to take me to
get to that yeah
I mean the interesting question is
because that that too in a sense there
are two components to it there's the
output which is very interesting in
terms of being uh grammatically written
with
what has to be said is a remarkably
lower low level of total garbage
okay
um well except in that even when these
academic papers were fake the whole
reply looked plausible okay
but it's comprehension of the question
does seem pretty impressive to me a tool
that since I was out for dinner with
last night uses it for is if he he
writes quite Advanced nutritional advice
and he puts his entire blog post or
whatever into it and says please rewrite
this at the third grade reading level
so he used it to dumb down very complex
technical talk and apparently that is
very very successful I haven't tried
that but
so I would if you asked it to we all
know that thing PowerPoint Shakespeare
um but if you asked it to take something
you'd written as an argument and the
condenses into PowerPoint simply
somebody else sent me the thing where
they'd asked me to ask Chet gdbt to
summarize uh you know my books or work
or something and it did a pretty damn
good job I I have to say and then
there's the second question which is you
know uh are we nearing a point where the
speech interface or at least we actually
we're typing full sentences
to some extent replaces what you might
call the push button point-and-click
interface
um everything would just be speech
commands yeah so I mean it is
interesting in that okay
um
one of the things that's a sort of
interesting finding and I'm not quite
sure what the explanation is I think
there are multiple reasons but in
customer service for example
um
these are the live chat nordinately
slower than speech
okay
okay sorry are you back on can you hear
me I can yep
oh for some weird reason it's it's but
okay I don't know uh let me try this I
need to get back onto the headphones
well let's drop the headphones I think
you might have poked it with your hand
ah [__] okay well don't worry
um uh people people weirdly really
really like
um
uh people really really like
[Music]
never mind okay
um people really like live chat as a
form of customer service yes the way you
make it work economically is the people
who are doing the live chat both use
sort of boilerplate answers which they
can just cut and paste in many cases
they don't have to type the whole thing
from scratch
and they're also handling three
customers simultaneously
which is how you make it work
economically but it's much much slower
than the spoken phone call and yet the
levels of customer satisfaction even
though it's slower are much much higher
is that because you can do something
else whilst you're chatting to them
yeah I think I think I think probably
multiple reasons a I suppose if they
have to pass you under somebody else uh
the you know the transcript can get
passed on to the next person so you
don't have that infuriating thing of
having to repeat yourself
that must be part of it there is an
interesting question which is are people
actually happier with you know we
obviously defaulted to this
point-and-click interface uh for a time
when it was much much faster and
pleasant and gave us an illusion of
control whereas one of the things that
makes voice interfaces absolutely
hopeless is when you know I mean Alexa
is by no means you know I mean for
example local train times
um uh invoice at my local station from
which I nearly was traveling to London
is called Oxford which is spelled
o-t-f-o-r-d well I mean forget about
asking about trains from Oxford because
nine times out of ten you'll get a list
of trains going to digits from Oxford
um uh but there is there is there is an
element where if the voice or text
perception was good enough and didn't
generate absolutely nonsensical
responses
you know or responses that were totally
blind to context like the time when I
used might have been Google in this case
uh I was driving home from work and I
wanted pharmacies that were currently
open
and it gave me a list of pharmacies in
Atlanta Georgia which were indeed
currently open of relativity
okay and um
so it may be I'm not I suppose
um you know that there may be a kind of
component where um
where strangely we go back to command
prompts with our interaction with with
computers
we're actually just using spoken
language or typed language is so much
easier than going through some weird
routine of button pressing and menu
pointing I wonder whether there's a
concern about the amount of control that
people have so we've spoken about this
on the show before where someone would
much rather be killed by a person
driving than injured by an automatic
driving vehicle because there's just
something if you were to put a vocal
prompt into uh some sort of word
processor or some sort of computer and
it got it wrong you would feel so
aggrieved you would feel completely hard
done by if you meant it to order from
this particular restaurant and it
ordered from somewhere else whereas if
you press the button at least you feel
culpable for it and I wonder whether it
might just be a case of acclimatizing to
your level of uh towards other words you
know the thing would have to repeat you
repeat the booking word for word do you
mean it's the last days of the Raj India
in a restaurant yes exactly yeah what
have you been yeah what have you been
obsessing
it's worth noting that when you go back
to my childhood you know the most of you
know orac you may remember from Blake
seven no you don't you don't remember
Blake seven at all okay but the one one
of the common interviews well how for
that matter okay the interface with the
computer was assumed to be speech
you know howl did not have a graphical
user interface right
and so there is something really really
interesting there which is that you can
um
uh and I mean the great problem you have
with Amazon Alexa is they've spent
billions on the thing and 90 of the
requests are basically for the time the
weather or something you know there is
one huge benefit by the way of Alexa
which I discovered which is that when
you're half awake early in the morning
that uncomfortable as I am about having
a lecture in the bedroom for obvious
reasons okay
um uh when you're half awake you can
find out what the time is without
opening your eyes
now once you've opened your eyes to look
at a digital clock there's a danger that
you then wake up but if Alexa replies
while your eyes are still shut then it's
actually you know 457 then you can
basically doze off straight back to
sleep again without that problem of of
searing off your retinas by looking at a
digital clock in the middle of the
guitar
it is a game of chicken when you wake up
on the morning to know when you wake up
it is absolutely a game of chicken yeah
how much light do I want to let it what
have you been obsessed by recently have
you had any new purchases we've spoken I
think in the past I want to say you
tried to get me to buy a glass-sided
toaster I didn't yeah I didn't become
part of your movement there although I
did get my parents to buy a airfryer and
then they upgraded to an air fryer with
pressure cooker in one wow went to the
whole Ninja thing right oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're happy with it oh
they they are I don't think that they
use anything else I don't think that
they did it sits on top of the cooker
and now is is the cooker in itself so
what else has there been anything else
you afford Mustang Mackie glass-sided
toaster and okay that's very very
interesting so the um I have to say
um the the airfryer continues its magic
the Japanese toilet uh never loses its
magic I'm down here in deal where I
don't have a Japanese toilet and the gap
between using a Japanese toilet and
using a conventional toilet is roughly
equivalent to the gap between
um using a conventional toilet and
[__] in a bucket in prison okay
right okay that's roughly speaking with
you know the uh the yawning sense of
kind of reversion you feel when you go
from using a Japanese toilet to a
conventional one it's barbaric it's
ridiculous and it will just stop
um
the airfryer maintains its magic I
mentioned these bone conducting
headphones which I think for a joggers
be the elderly and see people who don't
want to become disoriented by you know
walking around with no knowledge of what
what what's going on around them okay
um which tends to happen with noise
canceling headphones I like the fact
that they cancel noise but it's also
kind of disquieting in a way you can
turn it on and off and around that
um so those are interesting in that they
have an application and for certain
people I think can be very very useful
um my father's stair lift
I strongly suspect to anybody elderly uh
listening to this or anybody with a long
memory listening to this that almost
everybody leaves getting a stair lift
too long too late
because they want to resist they have
all this whole thing about the exercise
of going up and down stairs is good for
you they want to retain Independence as
long as they can well there's no
compulsion to use a stair lift simply
because you have one but to my father
that's been absolutely transformative
what I also didn't realize is you don't
need to put any you don't need to drill
into the wall at all the whole track for
the stair lift is a fairly discreet
strip of metal that just goes up the
flight of stairs and is basically uh
screwed into the wood of the stairs not
into the masonry of the wall
um so as an employer I I think what you
might call guaranto Tech uh of how you
manage aging and caring through
technology will be an enormous source of
progress
um uh in the next 10 years and a very
worthwhile area for investment I think
gerund Texas yeah
uh other other things which um uh
because the things that where the magic
never really goes
um
have gone back to using a tablet again
after about a four-year hiatus
um
I got my Samsung Galaxy S8 the eight
inch
um thing which I have to say is is
absolutely excellent
um and that's mainly for reading and um
uh uh reading newspapers and uh reading
books Etc and watching films
occasionally
um I'm happy to have gone back to a
tablet after as I said after a long
period making do without one
um no the other the other point I would
make about the electric car is that the
well I've I've had one now for I guess
it must be a year and four months or
something one I don't have charging at
home and um I'm shortly to get charging
installed at home but um I I delayed and
fudged around and needed to liaise with
the neighbors about having a new
three-phase Supply
um uh put in and uh oddly given that
that's a period of about 15 16 months I
have found it surprisingly
non-problematic to actually have an
electric car without home charging so
for any londoners this thing you go well
we can't get an electric car because
there's nowhere for us to charge you
know charge at home particularly given
the athlete feeble distances London has
managed to drive
um
uh I don't think that there is actually
a problem I I genuinely don't think that
is an issue
um in the slightest
um and also the
the weird pleasure of driving an
electric car with regenerative braking
and single pedal driving uh is a
pleasure that never goes away or hasn't
yet I drove my first uh Tesla Model
why is that the big one why is the big
one uh the taller one yeah correct um
but it was the
ludicrous or the Plaid edition of this
thing or whatever and for the first time
ever I was just pulling it after going
from not to 16 some terrifying amount of
time uh I then was trying to pull around
the corner and took my foot off the
accelerator like you would to allow it
to Coast around the corner yes and the
[__] thing stopped
I thought hang on a second so I I take
my foot off of the accelerator and the
brakes get deployed yes like okay right
this is an entire new type of driving
most of the braking will actually be
regenerative so that's it so
uh in a conventional car particularly in
automatic when you take the foot of the
accelerator the car continues to Coast
creeps because it would be it would be
way would it be wasteful for it not to
Coast uh in a sense
because you'd be throwing away momentum
okay whereas an electric car because the
momentum actually gets recaptured by the
battery
um uh there's no particular reason why
uh you shouldn't just decelerate with
the accelerator uh with no particular
need I mean I go for miles at a time
without using the brakes in any shape or
form uh you just anticipate by
throttling off the car slows down the
brake lights come on even if the brakes
aren't deployed sometimes to notified
cars behind you that you're going to be
accelerating at a fastest Pace than they
might typically expect
um
but it's actually
um uh it's a lovely way to drive partly
because you don't have a feeling of
resentment when you lose speed what
makes cyclist wankers okay I I tried an
electric bike that strikes me as quite
an interesting technology for two
reasons which is that
um the dirty secret of bikes as I said
is that when you cycle uphill it's no
faster than walking
secondly there is only a limited range
of demographies and levels of physical
fitness who can really cycle thirdly
acceleration is painful and slow okay
fourthly very large areas of the Earth's
surface are totally all suited to
cycling I mean Lisbon for example or
bath okay or one of those hillies or
Durham I mean you know okay you know
having a bike in Durham Newcastle
wouldn't be terrible but there would be
chunks of Newcastle which would be awful
I imagine right
and um so you know when you factor that
in the electric bike which basically
means that uphill and accelerating and
for people who are less than you know
Lance Armstrong fit okay
um it actually becomes a viable mode of
Transport assuming the weather's good
enough
or assuming that you design a completely
different kind of bike which actually
has some sort of protection from the
elements which I suppose is another
consideration because the great
Advantage there is a you'll be able to
make bikes slightly inefficient fatter
tires for Comfort wider seats also
possibly some sort of rain shielding
because the electricity will basically
counterbalance the aerodynamic
inefficiencies of those things so that
you can actually cycling something which
isn't absolutely optimized around
titanium and
narrow tires which are hopeless in urban
environments for example you know you
know you hit a pothole at the wrong
angle and you know there's Total Carnage
and disaster so the electric bike is
interesting I have to say
um and um
uh
I I gave I gave one of those a brief
test drive and was quite and it was
quite quite quite impressed in fact
um it took a little bit of Mastery but
that's probably because it's bloody
years since I've cycled it all
um and uh other things
um
but that does strike me as quite
significant because
um one of the reasons and this is what
this is where I come back to the
electric car regenerative braking okay
one of the reasons cyclists are [__]
is that because accelerating is really
painful they have this mentality of
maintain momentum at any cost which
causes them to sort of leap onto the
pavement ignore red lights go at
precipitous speed through roundabouts
without paying much attention I don't
totally blame them for that because you
know if you imagine driving a car where
every time you press you press the
accelerator you know electrodes in your
testicles gave you a sharp burst of pain
you know we'd all drive like [__]
and in the bike you know because it's
painful getting up speed and it's slow
they have this sunk cost problem which
is they're desperately unwilling to slow
down in this it's absolutely necessary
but the great thing with the electric
card regenerative braking is because you
feel you're getting your energy back
when you slow you don't have that same
fear same resentence or feeling if
you're forced to slow down a bit instead
of going this bastard by turning so
slowly has robbed me of my hard-won
kinetic energy you just go oh okay
energy back into the tank for later and
then off you go again
electric vehicles are very very good for
things like delivery vehicles which do a
lot of stop go motoring well I mean that
was the original milk float right in the
UK that was a Tesla before it was a
Tesla what's happening you you're moving
through different Vapes here what's
happening with the vaping debate at the
moment I've seen uh certain companies
have been cracked down on for uh making
flavors that are basically too tasty
that kind of entice young younger kids
to get into vaping and stuff like that
my own views this is a total nonsense
okay in that this
um
watch if I know it's not the world's
most common are you commonly use
streaming service but Plex
has which you can get on Smart TVs and
so on and Google Chrome tv someone once
gave me an illegal login to that where I
could watch every movie ever created
someone gave me like an access code to
it's like a hard drive it's like you can
stream hard drives and stuff right yeah
absolutely right but Plex has on it a
film called One Billion Lives which is
obviously made by vaping enthusiasts but
it actually
um Co-op some pretty hard ass serious
medical scientists talking about the
fact that you know because in middle
class Western milia the number of people
smoking is small
um then people tend to think of the
smoking problem as having been solved
but if you take the world's population
as a whole they would uh their argument
is that look The Wider legalization
um the um deregulation of vaping and
other forms of nicotine delivery device
has the potential to save a billion
lives and their accusations sometimes
leveled at Big Pharma some have not been
tobacco big tobacco is oddly in a sense
because they've invested in vaping
Technologies they're not actually the um
uh the evil presence you might have
expected but big Pharma which had
invested in a lot of Fairly ineffectual
patches and sprays and guns only to find
that at the last minute some hipsters
came up with a better idea
um
has played dirty and the the extent to
which governments have been persuaded to
ban flavors to band disposables for
example there's an environmental case
for batting disposables
um and also the endless
recurrence of this argument oh but
children have been doing it okay well my
argument there is I've got two children
aged 21 at University surrounded by a
pretty active drug culture and a lot of
booze okay worry number 407 on my list
is they might take up vaping okay of all
the things they could do you know
something which has actually pretty
trivial short medium and I would argue
long-term effects that has very few
negative externalities on the people
around them
um
you know the demonization of nicotine as
distinct from
um burning tobacco
has been one of the most extraordinary
kind of wasted human efforts or
misdirected human efforts uh of the last
20 years because it's you know it's
coffee basically and there's you know as
a drug it's that kind of thing now
um the children argument that one of the
great things is that flavors by getting
you hooked on a flavor that's very
unlike the flavor of burning tobacco is
a great way of getting people off
smoking right because switching back to
smoking cigarettes
and kind of horrible
um does it you know do I care that 23
year olds who can get hold of ecstasy
you know LSD cocaine
Etc do I care that they're buying else
bars not really
and I I always think it's a you know
that oh the children oh the young people
it's got a [__] argument actually
because
um
I mean off you know I shouldn't say this
I won't say it actually because I prefer
not to share the information but
actually I mean even smoking cigarettes
below a certain age provided you quit
and that's a very big provided by the
way
um doesn't have massively deleterious
effects on on health yeah the concern is
the Gateway right I mean I've noticed
this especially since being in Texas
it's a Gateway out uh it really is a
gateway is it a gateway to cigarettes
we've seen absolutely zero evidence of
that I would have said yeah that's a
good point that's a really good point
actually and it is definitely the
Gateway so what's happening so you're in
Texas at the moment yeah so I live here
now I've been here for just under a year
and um because of the
existing culture of dip dipping tobacco
over here yeah um snooze those little
pillowcases yes that you slot in between
your lip and your gum those are
insanely popular over here this is
absolutely everyone hammers these and
they come in all manner of different
flavors and different sizes they they do
a two milligram all the way up to a 20
milligram nicotine dosage yeah yeah I
mean 20 milligram would make me
immediately want to throw up but yeah
that's that's something that people use
but it's so interesting because the
culture's already been primed here
through the existing Heritage of dip and
using dipping tobacco which this is the
cooler less disgusting I don't need to
have a bottle and into it every
30 seconds or whatever because I've got
some awful buildup in my mouth uh that's
that's incredibly popular over here
so so how is Texas more liberal than
most States in regulating vaping as well
I'm not sure about that I mean the Vapes
are everywhere they're sold on the
street they're sold in corner shops
people are using them indoors in comedy
clubs and gigs in bars everywhere that I
go yeah this is this is where I like
Texas actually I don't know what people
said before I moved here everyone was
like oh you're going to kind of the
diluted down
like PG version of Texas by going to
Austin it's a blue dog that is true yeah
it's a blue dot in a red ocean and I
don't know it might just be a selection
effect for the people that I hang around
but I'm like I see no no hints of blue
here at all like there's I don't see a
massive amount of progressivism or
liberal overreach or you know the the
woke tards in the street like there's
none of that that I see in Austin it
just seems like it just seems like Texas
with young people
it's University it's had a great music
town it's fantastic Food Town it's a
brilliant town and actually uh also
people tend to take on to an extent the
mores of the of the pre-existing culture
um and I I I've only been I've only been
to Austin once I absolutely loved it but
um
uh I um uh but I also I also love
Houston Dallas everywhere I've been in
Texas I found people absolutely Charming
I I like that thing of screw this I'm
gonna Vape at the comedy club you know
that's like kind of independence of my
independent mindedness yeah is really
really healthy talk to me you've been
big into this ergodicity thing for for
quite a while I was thinking about how
that and Bayesian updating and all the
rest of it kind of applies to people's
life design have you got a
a good way that people can increase
their chances of getting lucky in life
one thing I think that you might say is
an intelligent evolutionary adaptation
is that the younger it's more
experimental in the old for a reason
um which is that they have less
experience to draw on so they need to
experiment more
but they also have more future life to
profit from experimentation
so if older people become more
conservative it's partly a perfectly
rational response effectively summed up
in the phrase I know what I like
okay and they have more experience to
draw on
and therefore
um you know the likelihood that they'll
suddenly discover a new holiday
destination which is 200 better than
their best current estimate of what a
holiday destination would be is low when
you're 70 whereas when you're 25 it's
it's by no means impossible right you
can discover something which is
sensationally better
um that's interesting
the fact that when you're old even if
you do discover something sensationally
better you've only got five years to
enjoy it also probably makes older
people conservative because the lifetime
remaining gains to experimentation are
also shorter so the fact that we see
that decline in openness as people go on
through life is uh is to some extent
probably a sensible evolutionary
mechanism in all kinds of ways so is
there is the applied solution there for
younger people to say yes to monu
experiences to go on adventures but but
not to get massively angry with older
people
uh for not doing so there's another book
which I really recommend actually to
everybody listening called algorithms to
live by
which is by I think Brian Christian and
somebody Griffiths
um of Griffith actually and
um uh one of the most interesting things
which if you're old was one of the best
things I've read in terms of uh
generally uplifting information the
reason when you get older that you find
it often slower to retrieve information
is not because of deteriorating mental
faculties it's because you know more
okay or you've accumulated more
information and therefore more of what
you know needs to be stored in kind of
the slower access parts of the brain
so that one of the reasons why you know
I mean
you notice this extraordinary if you see
there's a university ChalleNGe Program
in the UK and then there's the kind of
there's the celebrity University
challenge around Christmas where people
tend to be in their 40s and 50s and the
people of their 40s and 50s kind of know
more but they're much much slower at
extracting the information and the
reason is that the amount that can be
stored on kind of RAM
is finite and therefore more of what you
know as an old person actually takes
time to retrieve so much wisdom that
you've got to dig through and and
actually if you told her you know
because a lot of people when they hit
their 40s and 50s are convinced that
this phenomenon is a sign of mental
deterioration
you know you know you go yeah you know
French chat ate a cake did get in you
know Marcel Buck proust right whereas
the 22 year old on University challenge
just goes air Marcel Bruce okay is
deeply disquieting I think to a lot of
older people and if you told them this
it would massively cheer them up
just as actually I think it's quite
important to tell people that
um is it particularly men that your
level of Happiness weirdly tends to uh
be a little bit u-shaped that people in
middle age have the lowest level of Life
satisfaction and then it actually rises
again more or less continuously after
you pass through sort of Middleton is it
middle to late middle age I can't
remember but there's some period the
biggest uh the biggest suicide risk for
men at the moment is 40 to 45.
it seems to be this was uh Max Dickens
and Matt Rudd uh both two separate books
last year uh one was Billy no mates and
the other from uh Matt Rudd who is the
guy from the Sunday Times I can't quite
remember the name of it but he was good
and he was on the show
um was
algorithms to live by the book where
Brian suggested that if you were trying
to find a partner you should yeah
33 people in and then once you find a
person who is better than those first 33
you just go with them yeah
I don't know because you probably don't
have to have an extensive relationship
with all 33 you know because that will
you know living with people for a year
and then ditching them 33 times would
not make you popular perhaps
um but the the it's known for in a very
sexist way as the secretary problem
because it was first posed as a
um you could only interview secretaries
one at a time
uh you um once you've rejected someone
you have no chance of following up it's
a slightly artificial artificial
depiction of the problem and the
question is how you know how many should
you interview uh before you reach this
point where you go okay the next one who
comes along and it's it's partly the
explore exploits trade-off and it's
partly the trade-off between uh having
too little information to Benchmark what
a good secretary might be like versus
having too few secretaries left that
you're in danger of running out
and so I think it is if you have a
hundred secretaries lined up I think the
optimal strategy is something is it 60
something I think it was a currency I
thought it was in the 30s yeah I think
it might be in the 30s um the interview
the first 30 and then you've you've set
your Peak the best of the 30 you've seen
and then the next as soon as one comes
along who's better than or as good as
that you choose that away you go one of
the things that I've been noticing
online especially in the post-trump
world this Allure of black and white
thinking which has been quite
reductionist people uh seem to be ever
more seduced by uh
low nuance
yes I've actually
so for example the evening expresses
itself with
um being unwilling to accept that
something might be acceptable in a
comedy club which is unacceptable in a
business meeting or a church meeting or
whatever it may be yes so the
unwillingness to acknowledge the fact
that the rules change according to
context
um
and therefore demanding that you can and
the thing the thing about it is I think
it is characteristic of people in their
late teens and perhaps early twenties I
think there's something kind of slightly
sophomoric about it in that most older
people once they've been particularly if
they spend any time working in an office
know that
the answer to a hell of a lot of
questions is it depends okay
and there's something fundamentally
wrong with our education system if it
isn't effectively showing people
that a very large number of questions
should be answered with I don't know I
need more information
and this need to be able to make an
absolute pronouncement on almost
anything
regardless of context
uh is it is fundamentally a bit weird so
if you take the transgender question you
know
well here's an example okay
in every single social situation I can
imagine okay you would treat a
transgender person uh uh uh as a member
of their preferred gender
um in accordance with their identity
but as a doctor it would be completely
wrong to treat a transgender person as
though they were female okay because
obviously you have to make an
acknowledgment for special circumstances
and therefore it doesn't seem to be
impossible that you can say well maybe
in prisons or women as refuges we need
to actually rethink this General
principle in other words you have a
principle which is true to the extent
that it is possible to make it true but
where you may have to actually make
concessions according to certain
particular situations in the same but I
I had a it's a very simple thing which
is
um I'll argue with the classic example
of this which is something which divides
a completely different group of people I
not uh you know turfs or Builders from
the actual feminists which is in the UK
that apologies to Americans because the
general patterns of behavior are totally
different in the US okay is it okay to
drive in the Middle Lane of the motorway
okay the answer to that is actually and
people people will take an incredibly
strong View
and the answer to that is cut has to be
it depends right because given that cars
can only travel at a slower speed when
you have a high level of traffic density
okay if you had everybody traveling at
60 miles an hour and insisting on all
traveling on the left-hand Lane of the
motorway leaving the other two lanes
empty okay that would massively slow
down traffic it'd be an incredible waste
to Road okay
so it is not actually wrong to use the
Middle Lane of the motorway under all
circumstances you should obviously be
fairly attentive to what's happening
behind you and so on and so forth but
what people want to do is they they
don't accept this fact that in a complex
system you occasionally need to take
account of more than one or two or three
factors in making a decision
what's this Allure towards black and
white thinking or the uh displeasure
that people have with more subtle or
complex or nuanced opinions where does
that come from do you think
um you get a lot of people well you
could argue uh that um a lot of people
found that Clarity and religion uh a
hundred years ago
that people who wanted that I need to be
told you know you know a series of good
heuristics by which to live life without
having to work everything out for first
principles which isn't a totally
ridiculous requirements okay uh they
would you know they would have found a
religion to accommodate that or that you
know something of that kind whereas I
the one thing that does worry me is does
it come from our education system
which is leading people to believe that
there must be a right answer there is an
up in other words
you know what are the interesting things
when you get curious about decision
science is not everything's an
optimization problem they're an awful
lot of human behaviors which make no
sense to people who are inverted commas
rationalists because they assume that
what the person is trying to do is to
optimize when actually what they're
trying to do is to de-catastrophize at
the same Talib and I uh the the
observation that people in Milan railway
station are eating at McDonald's okay
they're not trying to get the best meal
they can find in Milan okay what they're
doing is basically you know there will
be search costs and everything else
attributed to that granted but what
they're trying to do is to get something
to eat which has a very very low chance
of making the meal or being
disappointing or a rip-off and
McDonald's is absolutely brilliant at
not being crap
and so depend you know it's very very
dangerous to declare people irrational
unless you know deep down both
consciously and unconsciously what
they're really trying to do
and brand preference I always give the
argument that a large part of brand
preference is not I want Samsung TVs
because they're better but it's I'll
happily pay a hundred bucks more for a
Samsung TV because I'm fairly confident
it's not going to be [__]
and when you think about it the
reputational mechanism works because if
you've invested billions in your brand
as a massive sunk costs you have much
more to lose in terms of future revenue
and profit through selling a [__]
television
than someone who nobody's ever heard of
you know whether you go on Amazon and
search for TV and you get all those kind
of scrabble-racked Brands called rujagu
or whatever right well why should they
care why should they invest in quality
control because they don't really have a
reputation at stake in the first place I
heard that Sky glass
which was attempt yep was uh I I saw a
bunch of reviews as it was coming out
and then once it came out from tech
people and it just got smashed it got
completely annihilated as the protein
pancake problem which is what I've
referred to when you try and blend two
products that previously were very well
optimized on their own into one product
which is [__] than either of them
were and worse than they both would be
separately so protein powders have been
pretty well optimized they're quite
tasty they're pretty much a Nesquik
that's got 30 grams of protein in
pancakes for almost all of time have
been fantastic if you try and make good
protein pancakes they usually end up
being a clumpy horrible mess and what
Sky's tried to do is integrate your Sky
membership into a television so that it
is a One-Stop shop but the TV
underperforms the sky system the
interacts with it is bad and it's trying
to beat a Kindle Fire stick which is
absolutely blazing fast and already
people's existing fantastic Samsung TV
which they they know and the interface
is optimized as well
it's very interesting isn't it because I
mean one of the things I talk about with
television the other way which is
fascinating is that
um uh
there is an amount of money and nobody
knows what it is I imagine you could get
it to a freedom of information request
that the BBC has to pay Samsung to put
iPlayer in a prominent position and the
Samsung Smart Hub
and Samsung has it in its power indeed
has already done so
to make the Hub the default starting
point for all viewing periods
when I first got a Samsung TV years ago
you could activate the Hub but it was by
pressing a very weird button on which
was one of about 47 buttons on the
remote control as well we all know you
never press the weird buttons on your
remote control because they make your TV
go weird I'll recovery for you know the
next half hour the aspect ratios are for
all of the blacks
green number two appear by which I mean
literally a number two appears in the
top left of the screen you know and you
can't make it go away you know that kind
of thing and
the modern Samsung TV comes with two
remote controls one of which is
blissfully simple and that's the one you
use all the time and every time you
you're not sure what to do you press a
button with a house on it which is
something we feel incredibly comfortable
doing you either press back or house and
surprise surprise that takes you to the
Samsung Smart Hub it previously we
turned on a TV and probably it was
broadcast TV by default then it was Sky
by default and now it's whatever Samsung
wants it to be I love the power they
enjoy in that is absolutely spectacular
yes so there will be at some point later
this year I haven't signed a contract
yet but
um this podcast is going to be featured
on a number of Airlines and it's going
to be able to be used in in-flight
entertainment and as the discussion has
gone on I asked this particular guy that
is handling the acquisition of the
content on the library
um what he intends on doing with it and
he said some insane percentage image of
what gets viewed on in-flight
entertainment is based on the first
screen's tiles of what shows up so if
you want everybody to watch bullet train
with Brad Pitt and that's tile number
three of six it's going to get it's the
same as being above the fold on Google
right it's like you're on the first page
of Google or basically you're not on
Google because everybody's going to
click on something on the first page
usually the first result
so it's a power law distribution the
thing that appears first gets 50 the
thing that appears yeah 100 going back
to the thing that you said about young
people I learned a concept that I gave a
term to from a friend gwynda Bogle and
he said
you can gauge someone's Ignorance by the
number of phenomena they explain with
the same answer those who blame many
different issues like War poverty or
pollution on just one cause like
capitalism a recycling explanations
because the demand for answers outstrips
their supply and I referred to that as
mono thinking
yeah a friend of mine calls it who's
Indian interesting he calls it
monotheism
we're not far off and as a Hindu he
always jokes that
um people in the west have a particular
propensity to monotherism because they
need one God to be behind everything
whereas he says it's a Hindu they're
completely happy with ambiguity
very good very and they're polytheistic
and I mean you know one of the
interesting ones is that you know all
social ills are down to social media
always strikes me as a bit too [__]
easy and I've always said one of my
mischievous ones is that uh some part of
what might be more obnoxious behavior in
people may be down to the decline in
smoking
now if you think about it if you have a
society if you have a society where uh
which 20 30 years ago 50 to 60 percent
of people regularly took what was a kind
of relaxing drug
okay
and now that's down to 10 you would
expect and of course the effect could be
magnified through social network effects
you would expect some change just as if
you put everybody on you know well open
it's okay to notice a change in general
Behavior surely Mass withdrawal from
drugs
is going to have some visible effect and
yet it has been assumed that that that
effect can't be there well why not I
mean one of the weirdest theories is
that you know there's an equal body of
belief which suggests a very eccentric
opinion that you know tobacco tea coffee
were major contributors to the
enlightenment
and so you know it is it is going to be
I have to say but you're right the the
the
um the need to go yes because capitalism
or you know there's a wonderful sketch
about this that dates back to you know
where you you recite something bad that
has happened to go Thatcher okay Brad
now you know it's it's is slightly
amusing to me which is that's
um to people born long after actually
Thatcher left office okay it's seen as
this absolutely pivotal changing point
in British history where beforehand
everything was supposedly absolutely
lovely it was like the Beatles and
flowers
completely forgetting the 1970s
altogether okay and then you had that
shirt and it all got nasty ingredients
self-interested and actually you know I
you know I mean tree Thatcher there was
a lot of extraordinary human
unpleasantness of all kinds maybe it was
less greedy that possibly is true but
there were all forms of manifestation of
genuine really malicious nastiness and
unpleasantness which if anything
diminished in the 1980s
um and it but it's so easy to have you
know as you said the stupidity I mean
actually creativity is also trying to
imagine
um things that could be much more
important factors that they are
generally given credit for
you know is this because
um
uh you know uh and actually I'm you know
I mean
uh it's a classic case of wanting the
rules of a simple system also to apply
to a complex system and I've been
talking to doctors recently about
obesity and it looks as though there may
be a group of people who are fat
very largely simply because they're um
their biome
uh the microbiota uh in their gut are
just very good at extracting energy from
food
and so you eat the same some people have
whatever reason a mix of microflora
which just aren't that great at
extracting calorific value from food I
mean things like you know I mean that's
another classic case in one the whole
Mind Body dualism thing
is a classic case of saying you know
okay in order to make the world
comprehensible I'm going to pretend
these things are entirely unrelated and
that you have willpower and that you
know your body and your bodily State
your digestive State and so forth has no
influence on your behavior and that's
again an attempt to say okay what we'll
do is we'll divide the world into water
type compartments for purposes of
tractability and comprehension and
proceed from there
and you know it's it's great in high
school physics to do that [__] it
doesn't really work anywhere else I mean
the extreme cases to say that science is
a bit of a calm because it hives off
that very small proportion of big
decisions that can actually be solved
definitively uh with a single right
answer and where you have all the data
you need to make the decision
um at the very start of the process okay
um and it hives those off uh pointster
is extraordinary success scenarios like
engineering
um and effectively lays the effectively
claims the credit for writing the exam
first and then solving it it's marking
its own homework to some extent because
anybody can be clever if they give them
5 000 exam questions okay and they're
asked to solve the ten they like the
best
what can people expect from you next
what are you doing for the rest of this
year
um I'm going to be writing a book called
slogan I think which is how um you know
it takes sort of 30 40 50 of the world's
best advertising lines and then dissects
them with kind of Behavioral Science
angle to say what they tell us about
ourselves are unconscious and our
society
that's cool so looking at persuasion I
think that can be quite interesting
um I'm a big fan of this business of
taking something and
um just looking at it through a peculiar
lens there's a wonderful thing on
YouTube which is I don't know if you've
ever seen the YouTube channel ask your
mortician have you no what's that no
okay so ask your optician as a woman who
works as a Undertaker or mortician in
the United States and there's a film she
made about 30 minutes long which is why
didn't JFK have an open casket or why
did JFK's casket stay closed now you
know the whole Kennedy assassination
thing is the most you know over raked uh
period of you know three days in 20th
century history pretty much okay you
know
every single thing every single person
in the crowd in the Zapruder film has
been subject to kind of microscopic
analysis but this is just taking the
whole thing and telling the story from
the point of view of you know the
morticians you know again obviously
where they got the tasket from the fact
that the fact that the um the fact that
the Secret Service commandeered the
hearse from the local mortician to drive
to Love Field I think it was where Air
Force One was waiting had no idea how to
operate the detaching mechanism that
allowed you to remove a coffin from the
earth and so in order to get the coffin
in the plane there were basically loads
of Secret Service guys with crowbars
basically scratching this thing to bits
no way to get it out of the Earth
because they refused to take anybody
they refused to take anybody from The
Undertakers with them they just
commandeer the vehicle
and so it what it is is it takes a very
very familiar well-worn story and just
adds a completely new perspective on it
you know sheds completely new lunch
that's where mono thinking becomes
interesting right if you have a single
optimizing functions
absolutely so that what I'd call that
nerd thinking where you actually take a
very very different uh point of view
um what you're doing then with mono
thinking is I think complementary to the
main dialogue
if all you're doing is taking everybody
else's mono thinking okay you're just
contributing to the two-dimensionality
of the whole field but if you actually
go over at 90 degrees orthogonally and
say okay uh what Shadows of cast if we
point the light over here that's when it
gets interesting amazing do you know
there's no no understanding that asking
mortician is the complete definitive
but what it does is it's a completely
fresh light on what was going on yes
very interesting very interesting thing
there was a Texas
um
uh I guess he must have been uh what do
you call it uh once you call it when you
have um the guy the guy who is the Texas
coroner in Dallas okay and one of the
reasons there was such a massive
conspiracy theory as they refused to let
this coroner perform the autopsy
and he's often portrayed as being a bit
of an ass because he refused to let the
president's body go and be flown back to
DC
but he was entirely correct if a death
occurs in Texas in his jurisdiction it's
absolutely his responsibility to do it
whether it's the president of the United
States or someone found dead in a shop
doorway and so it's very interesting
from that point of view because I'd
always heard of this guy as like being
like Mr difficult trying to muscle in I
don't know absolutely not not that case
at all he was entirely correct in what
he was trying to do and they were
entirely wrong and this is ask a
morticians yeah asking mortician I think
it's called yeah phenomenal um do you
know Richard shotton he wrote The Choice
Factory a few years ago I know Richard
very well he's absolutely fantastic
behavioral scientist he's got a new book
out this year he's got a new book out
I've got it if I've got it right but
remind me what the book's called it's
called um give me one second I'll get it
up in my calendar you might get it
before me though
um where is he on is it next week no is
it the week after no is it the week
after that there it is oh no that's
Richard rangham the guy that wrote uh
who is also great Richard shotton is
coming on where the [__] is he uh anyway
he's in he's in here somewhere anyway
there's I'm very excited for that I know
that you and him have a lot of crossover
um do you know the story of how his uh
what's it called Astro 10 his company
name
no I I because my wife was just asking
about that saying what's this Astro 10
thing so go on tell me the story you'll
have to ask him for the full the full
description however
he found online some uh company that had
used a behavioral Insight in a very
smart way and he loved it he then
registered astro10.com and all of his
email addresses and went to companies
house and maybe got the trademark as
well and all the rest of it and then
only later realized that it was actually
called Astro Teng or something there was
a g on the end and I see he'd typo the
entire thing he'd actually misspelled
this uh but preferred the version of it
that he came up with and now he's
lumbered with it for the rest of time
uh Oprah Winfrey is a similar case where
actually the Old Testament character is
called orpa not Oprah
and the cleverest one of all which was a
deliberate kind of perversity Cliff
Richard who will be probably not well
known to American listeners but was a
massive kind of uh pop star and still is
indeed in the UK he's kind of the I
suppose you might sort of vehicle in the
British Johnny Halliday okay
but he was originally I can't remember
what his real name is but it's not Cliff
Richard okay these originally going to
be called Cliff Richards
and I think he was his managers who said
no no we'll call you Cliff Richard
why because then every time you get
interviewed on TV the interview is going
to call you Cliff Richards or call you
Mr Richards and you get a chance to
correct him which means everybody gets
to hear your name twice
wow
so that was the uh
um I mean the surprising actually that a
surprising number of names arise through
completely there's another name which
also arose to a complete
misunderstanding do you know the story
do you know the story of Salvador Dali
of why so Salvador Dali's parents had a
child born about nine months before Dali
was and they named him Salvador Dali and
he died only a couple of days after he
was born they're then basically almost
immediately conceived again and had
another child that was born nine months
later and they were adamant that he was
a Reincarnation of that dead son so they
called him Salvador they called him the
name of the son that had already gone
uh Elvis is interesting because it's
widely believed that
um the middle name of Elvis Aaron
Presley spelled a-r-o-n okay is an
ignorant uh typo or or misspelling
either by the parents or by the um
whoever registered the birth in fact
it's the Welsh spelling of Aaron and
whether Elvis is Welsh or not is open to
debate um stop trying to you would you
have a lot of affinity with the Welsh
people and Country stop trying to adopt
everybody for your absolutely
his dad was convinced I think that they
were Welsh I was convinced that
President he came from the priscelli
hills where there is wait for it a
church of Saint Elvis there's only one
church of Saint Elvis anywhere in the
world it's in pembrokeshire not far from
the priscelli hills I think what might
have been happening is Vernon was it
Elvis's Dad I think I think it was
verbum
um Vernon was convinced of the family as
well so in the same way but by the way
that Johnny Cash seemed to be actually
convinced that he was part native
American even though his ancestry was
entirely Scottish here's a question for
you here's a question as a proud loosely
associated Welshman
how how has it become that Irish has a
cultural impact on the world you've got
Irish areas in New York people
understand St Patrick's Day they've
generally got themselves a a cultural
foothold to Scots as well the bagpipes
they've got the hats they've got The
Tartan they've got everything yeah well
should the United States
um suddenly enough they were Fair Thomas
Jefferson okay basically Welsh
um uh but the they seem to assimilate
faster and you get Welsh communities in
Pennsylvania mining communities you get
all those places called Bethesda and so
forth you also get those places and Bryn
Mawr which I think is in Connecticut
isn't it must be named after the Welsh
Bryn Mawr
um but so you you do you do get Welsh
communities and obviously Patagonia in
uh
uh in in in in South America
what
okay
um
uh but they haven't done as good a job
of marketing themselves
uh as
um uh because the Welsh um I think the
Welsh what you might call diaspora and
Hillary Clinton for example is part
Welsh uh will agree to differ on Elvis I
have no idea to be able to do honest
um uh about Elvis Presley's bloodline
and I'm sure that people have researched
it in absolutely enormous depth uh but
um uh no you know whereas Trump would
mention his scottishness I don't think
Hillary Clinton ever mentioned her Welsh
nurse what The Branding problem is with
well she would have been absolutely no
electoral value to play on your
emotionless Hillary or having problems
uh and um I mean I've also you know and
um uh Frank Lloyd Wright was conscious
of his welshness now interestingly uh so
you know uh Taliesin is um
uh a Welsh phrase meaning shining brow
and uh Frank was was pretty conscious of
his Welsh ancestry uh were there other
there was also an absolutely fantastic
mafioso character in Chicago who is kind
of a number two to Al Capone called
Murray the camel Humphries whose parents
I think came from Kano in powers or
somewhere
um but um
so you have this kind of you know I mean
undoubtedly they're pretty well
represented proportionately
um although Davis has always felt is in
the US rather than IES
um the Jefferson Davis I guess is
actually I think you know he's actually
a Welsh origin but it but the the the
interest in
promulgating or promoting it versus the
Irish or the Scots
um seems to be much much lower I have to
say maybe maybe you could try and appeal
to the Welsh government
and speak to them and say if you could
do a Rebrand perhaps
no so um let me I'll think of a few more
there are um actually the early
presidents were disproportionate
Washington I don't think was but I've
got a vague idea that Adams and and
quite a few of the early presidents
um were
um were fairly heavily Welsh and then um
there's also an interesting intonation
which may or may not be true that Welsh
surnames are quite common among
African-Americans because of a Welsh
Quaker thing where things like
underground railroads and so forth tend
to be run by Quakers who
tended to be Welsh but I I've read that
how plausible that is I don't know it
could be highly fanciful
um
but um no it is it is kind of
interesting
um because I know you could I suppose
you could say you know
do Anglo-Saxon Americans have a
particular sense of uh identity too
um which is an interesting question you
know and so the the Scots and the Irish
and there's a little you know you think
you're absolutely right that the small
country syndrome where people tend to be
slightly more proud of ancestry from a
less populous country
um but again I suppose you know German
Americans have never you know I mean the
population of the US is probably more
German by ancestry than it is British
not quite
um interesting question
um uh possibly more than English but if
you include the whole of the British
Isles no
um but uh you you get the odd you get
the odd thing in Milwaukee places like
that just as you get the Swedish Thing
in in Minnesota I would love to hear a
Welsh American Blended accent that would
be that would be one hell of a cacophony
coming out
yeah I mean one Theory I did here is
that the Welsh being fairly sort of easy
going
um uh you know wood within one
generation basically completely blend in
either just allowed themselves to dilute
down into the local colors and just
dilute Dan the very funny comedian who I
think you'll enjoy called Andrew
is it Schultz you come across him yeah
he's been on the show oh he's been on
the show yeah
I thought what was absolutely hysterical
is I was watching him on YouTube doing a
show in Hawaii taking the piss out of
people who moved to Hawaii because he
said his mother's Scottish okay was born
in Scotland and she's lived in New York
for almost all her adult life but she is
still completely Scottish in Her speech
and her behavior and mannerisms she said
you don't get my mother going [__] you
Etc but people move to Hawaii and three
weeks later they're all there going
Aloha and using Hawaiian phrases he was
kind of calling out [__] calling
everyone a howling that's what they call
the people that are from out of town
look Rory let's bring this one home I
always love speaking to you mate
um I'm gonna be back in London at some
point this year so I'll definitely give
you enough to catch up the absolutely
Splendid yeah thank you mate catch you
later on all the best what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]